ja also in der heutigen sitzung werden
wir die abschlussdiskussion dieses
seminares über themen der existenz
machen bevor wir darauf kommen wie immer
die zusammenfassung der letzten sitzung
das war eine sehr zukunft zugewandte
sitzung weil wir uns damit solchen
spannenden existenzen wie fiktionalen
gegenständen wie virtuellen realitäten
und mit unmöglichen gegenständen auch am
rande beschäftigt haben wie sie alexis
meinung entwickelt hat und wir hatten
uns folgende fragen überlegt und liefern
existieren fiktionale gegenstände wie
sherlock holmes welche unterschiedliche
auffassungen bezüglich fix oder
gegenstände gibt es welche ist dann
überzeugendsten welche neurologischen
status haben virtuelle realitäten oder
auch virtuelle gegenstände
man kann es noch genauer sagt auch
virtuelle ereignisse virtuelle
handlungen virtuelle prozesse
das sind so die fragen gewesen und jetzt
kann man zwischen verschiedenen arten
nicht existierende dinge unterscheiden
zum einen unmögliche gegenstände zum
beispiel runde quadrate deshalb diese
sogenannten meinung die amischen
gegenstände dann kann man weiter
unterscheiden zwischen fiktiven
gegenstände zb pegasus oder auch
sherlock holmes dann kann man zum
schluss noch auf simulationen bzw
virtuelle realitäten unterscheiden
virtuelle realitäten habe ich jetzt auch
in einfache anführungsstriche gesetzt
weil ich der meinung bin und auch andere
das virtuelle realitäten sehr wohl
existieren landläufig wird virtuelle
realität zu verstanden dass sich dabei
eigentlich um besonders komplexe
simulation handelt als das simulation
und virtuelle realität synonym gebraucht
werden kann ich glaube aber dass das
nicht das richtige verständnis von
virtueller realität ist sondern dass man
hier noch weiter differenzieren muss
dass auch virtuelle realitäten
wirkliche existenzform sind diese
verschiedenen arten nicht existierende
gegenstände wenn man jetzt einfach mal
sagte virtuelle realitäten sind auch
simulierte realität
diese verschiedenen arten nicht
effizient gegenstände existieren jedoch
nicht auf dieselbe weise nicht also
hielt sich der nichtexistenz können wir
noch weiter unterschreiben fiktive
gegenstände existieren zum beispiel nur
konsequenter weise nicht sie könnten
auch existieren bzw
hätten existieren können pegasus zb
dieses geflügelte pferd könnte
prinzipiell existieren man könnte zum
beispiel ein pferd mit einem vogel
kreuzen das wäre ja prinzipiell möglich
und dann hätte man ein fliehendes pferd
fliegendes pferd das heißt so etwas ist
logisch möglich das ist nicht unmöglich
ein rundes quadrat hingegen dieses
meinung die amische objekt kann aus
logischen gründen nicht existieren
es kann also unmöglich existieren da es
in sich an widerspruch berg simulationen
schließlich teilen mit der realität
bestimmte formale strukturen sie
modellieren die realität unter abwägung
von bestimmten aspekten
ich kann zum beispiel simulieren wie
sich ein auto in einem fahrverhalten
bewerte ich kann dann ein modell eines
autos entwickeln eine simulation da
werde ich natürlich das auto in der
regel etwas kleiner machen und ich werde
natürlich nicht alle details am auto
dran lassen
genauso kann ich eine wetterprognose
durch simulation erreichen
da muss ich immer von bestimmten
aspekten absehen auf die mir ist gerade
nicht ankommt das heißt simulationen am
immer eine gewisse struktur analogie zur
realität aber sie ist nicht die ganze
realität ist eine abbildung modellierung
so und jetzt können wir uns kennen sie
die fiktive gegenstände auch noch ein
paar gedanken machen
fiktive gegenstände und personen
sherlock holmes lassen sich auf
verschiedene weise verstehen die tiefe
anti royalisten vertreten die auffassung
dass fiktive gegen stimmte nicht
existieren und ich denke die
allermeisten menschen würden diese
auffassung auch vertreten natürlich
existiert sherlock holmes nicht ist auch
ganz klar fiktionale realisten hingegen
vertreten die these dass es fiktive
gegenstände gibt und dass diesen die
eigenschaft zukommt nicht zu existieren
was also spannend also es gibt
fiktionale gegenstände aber sie haben
die eigenschaft nicht zu existieren und
komisch das heißt fixen realisten neigen
dazu existenz als eine art von prädikat
zu verstehen welches intentionalen
gegenständen also gegenstand auf die wir
uns geistig beziehen können zukommt das
erinnert ein bisschen an dieses meinung
die amischen objekt auf jeden fall ist
es eine spannende unterscheidung und
jetzt können wir die fiktionalen anti
realisten weiter unterscheiden
es gibt die so genannten pessimisten
argumentieren dass fiktive gegenstände
in der wirklichen welt nicht existieren
jedoch in manchen möglichen verhalten
als szenarien die nicht logisch
widersprüchlich sind das ist als einfach
kurz gesagt die auffassung dass zb
pegasus eben in der wirklichen welt
nicht existiert aber eben in manchen
welten die logisch möglich sind
existieren könnte man spricht auch von
der möglichen welt neo meinung die
hander vertreten die auffassung dass
fiktive gegenstände nicht in raum und
zeit existieren dass sie jedoch
eigenschaften haben sie existieren nicht
sondern sucht ihren nur ein rundes
quadrat ist rund und quadratisch ohne
dabei existieren zu können
dennoch ist es ein internationaler
gegenstand unseres denkens und ebenso
hat auch sherlock holmes bestimmte
eigenschaften ohne zu existieren
das diesem eine mechanische position und
dann gibt es auch noch die sogenannten
kreationisten die argumentieren dass
fiktive gegenstand artefakte sind also
kunstgegenstände die kausal von ihren
autoren und gegebenenfalls sogar auch
von der einbildungskraft ihrer
so will und leser abhängen die
kreationisten entsprechend ungefähr der
position des extremismus nach kidd
feiern ich mache da oben rechts wieder
ein link hinein wo ich das video
verlinkt zu dieser sitzung in dem wir
uns mit kid fall befasst haben so jetzt
geht es also weiter
jetzt müssen wir uns den virtuellen
gegenständen zu das ist ein ganz
spannendes thema und zwar deswegen weil
durch die kommune krise die das thema
virtualität virtuelle realität immer
mehr jetzt ins zentrum rückt wir müssen
versuchen auf neue wege auf neuen wegen
bisher analog oder physikalische
strukturen zu nicht nur zu simulieren
zahlen eben auch zu realisieren
ich sagte schon mal was wir hier gerade
machen ist keine simulation der
universitätslehrer das ist kein bloßes
spiel sondern das ist wirkliche
universitäts wäre aber auf eine andere
weise und diese andere weiß dass es
gerade das virtuelle virtuelle
realitäten und gegenstände existieren
auf eine ganz besondere weise die
zunächst mal von fiktionen zu
unterscheiden ist ich werde im folgenden
aber noch dafür argumentieren dass
fiktionen und virtuelle realitäten auch
eine gemeinsamkeit aufweisen
zunächst muss jedoch virtuelle realität
von bluse simulation abgegrenzt werden
auch wenn wir im folgenden noch
argumentieren wird
virtuelle realität und simulation
gewisse gemeinsamkeiten aufweisen
simulationen sind abstraktionen der
realität während virtuelle realitäten ja
gerade eine eigene realität haben sollen
ein apfel einem computerspiel kann
entweder ein simulierter apfel sein der
diesem wirklichen physikalisch gegeben
zumindest optisch zum verwechseln
ähnlich sieht ihn nach zum beispiel
könnte man eben jetzt ein
ein schönes ab foto auf dem bildschirm
anzeigen und aus der ferne könnte man
glauben da liegt tatsächlich ein apfel
das wäre natürlich jetzt aber nur eine
simulation jetzt stellt sich die frage
was es dazu nötig dass wir aus einem
bloßen
jeden apfel einen virtuellen apfel
bekommen also ich würde die these
vertreten dass wenn wir jetzt wenn sie
jetzt ein apfel bild hier auf ihrem
monitor sehen dann ist das natürlich nur
zweidimensionales hat keine tiefe
sie können auch nicht anfassen sie könne
nicht essen das ist also vielleicht nur
ein simulierter apfel oder abgebildete
apfel
was muss jetzt noch hinzu kommt damit
auf diesem abschnitt der sich auf ihrem
bildschirm befindet das system ein
virtueller ein wirklicher ein virtueller
realer apfel wird ein virtueller apfel
muss kurz gesagt eine vom physikalischen
apfel von dem biologisch produzierten
apfel eine unabhängige funktion und
kausale rolle einnehmen er muss neue
eigenschaften die klammer fiktive
eigenschaften zunächst fiktive gewinnen
die den verlust von raum zeitlichen
eigenschaften kompensieren
also ein virtueller apfel wird natürlich
nicht nach apfel schmeckt dann werden
sie wahrscheinlich nicht schmecken
können
das heißt er muss ein bisschen andere
eigenschaften hin zu gewinnen die die
physikalischen eigenschaften die ihn
verliert kompensieren die den ersetzen
diese eigenschaften müssen ihm jedoch
verbindlich zu kommen dies kann zum
beispiel so geschehen dass der digitale
apfel als objekt in einem multiplayer
computerspiel eingeführt wird und für
alle nutzerinnen dieselben eigenschaften
aufweist das ist ganz wichtig wenn es
ein virtueller apfel sein sollen dann
musste objektiv existieren also für alle
nutzerinnen und nutzer auf dieselbe
weise zugänglich sein und nicht für
jeden nutzer anders sein
zb kann er einen virtuellen preis haben
diese virtuelle apfel dann wird schon
ein computer spielt er kann dann einen
bestimmten virtuellen ort liegen hat zum
beispiel vor einer künstlichen welt und
er kann eine bestimmte funktionen dem
spiel haben zb um nach dem virtuellen
verziert dieses apfels in ein höheres
level zu gelangen virtuelle äpfel teilt
also eigenschaften von fiktionen
es sind jedoch insofern realer als sie
in interaktive kontexten eine kausale
rolle einnehmen also wie ich schon sagte
wenn sie sich jetzt ein online
multiplayer computerspiel vorstellen
wie zum beispiel diablo oder second life
oder sonst ein spiel das multiplayer
mäßig gespielt wird dann kann es darin
objekte geben die apfel genannt werden
die vielleicht wie ein apfel aussehen
also simulator aspekt haben die aber
ganz bestimmte funktionen inne haben zb
dass sie magische eigenschaften haben
oder dass sie durch den verzehr dieses
apfel sowie eine neue funktion
freigeschaltet bekommen die sie im in
der wirklichen welt sozusagen in der
physikalischen welt nie bekämen durch
den verzehr eines apfels in dem jedoch
diese eigenschaften verbindlich sind für
alle nutzerinnen nutzer des
computerspiels wird dieser apfel nicht
mehr nur zu einer simulation wie ich
glaube es seien zu einer drittel
realität also zu einer wirklichen form
von existenz und realität virtuelle
gegenstände existieren nach einer
anderen raum und zeit logik als
physikalische gegenstände tun also ein
virtueller apfel der hat kein alter sie
können nicht sagen wie alt dieser apfel
ist es sei denn er wird dieser wert
würde diesen apfel zugesprochen werden
habe man könnte jetzt sagen diese
virtuelle apfel hat das alter ex ja das
wäre dann für alle nutzerinnen des
computerspiels verbindlich insofern
könnte man das sagen
aber dieses alter wäre ein anderes alter
als es ein alter ist wie es ein
physikalisch biologische apfel besitz
dieses alter können sie bestimmen
naturwissenschaftlich das alter eines
virtuellen objekt eben nicht hatte man
könnte eigentlich sagen virtuelle
objekte haben gar keine zeitlichkeit und
sie haben auch keine räumlichkeiten oder
zumindest eine andere und dann müsste
man sich fragen wie genau diese neue
raum und zeit look aussieht das können
wir heute noch diskutieren
virtuelle gegenstände besitzen einen
simulatoren an fiktionalen und einen
realen aspekt das ist mir jetzt in der
jüngsten zeit gekommen das möchte ich
auch zur diskussion stellen das kann
auch falsch sein
ich glaube eben dass wir virtualität und
simulation und fiktionalität nicht
unbedingt gegeneinander ausspielen
sollten natürlich ist virtuelle realität
mehr als nur eine simulation aber
virtuelle realität hat immer auch ein
bisschen was von sich
die nation warum weil es ja auf eine
andere weise etwas realisieren soll also
in dem ich jetzt hier eine virtuelle
lehre gegeben wird das seminar
orientiere ich mich natürlich schon
etwas an dem traditionellen seminar das
heißt ich simuliere es eine bestimmte
weise schon zum beispiel dem ich ihn ein
virtuelles whiteboard freigegeben hat
das ist eine gewisse simulation aber der
unterschied ist dass sie haben hier das
mit einer wirklichen lehre zu tun das
ist nicht nur ein spiel
sie bekommen danach credit points wenn
sie die seminare besucht haben und der
hausarbeit geschrieben haben diese mir
auch auf virtuelle weise nämlich als ein
pdf-dokument zu schicken es ist nicht
nur eine simulation es ist viel ernst
für real
und dazu kommt noch ein fiktionaler
aspekt weil ich bei diesem virtuellen
apfel gezeigt hatte diesen gegenständen
diesen virtuellen neue eigenschaften
zugesprochen werden können zu kommen
können die die vorbilder oder die
physikalischen objekte nicht haben zum
beispiel dass sie einen level
weiterkommen wenn sie diesen virtuellen
apfel eben verzieren
ein weiterer punkt wäre zum schluss noch
ich glaube dass der übergang von der
simulation und von der fiktion zur
virtuellen realität fließend geschieht
ich glaube dass dann aus der simulation
oder einer fiktion eine virtuelle
realität wird wem diese fiktion oder
simulation stabil genug ist dh wenn sie
objektiv wird für eine bestimmte gruppe
von nutzerinnen und nutzern
wenn es also so eine art inter
subjektiver einigung gibt über diese
gegenstände und wenn diese gegenstände
an die ganz besondere kausale rolle
spielen die man jetzt noch genauer
bestimmen müsste die ebenso verfasst ist
dass sie sich nicht mehr an der
physikalischen welt orientiert dass sie
irgendwann nicht mehr nur abbild
charakter hat zählen ein eigenleben eine
eigendynamik entwickelt ich glaube dann
können wir sagen haben wir es geschafft
uns von der bloßen simulation zu lösen
zum eigenen
realität und dann können plötzlich
fiktionale eigenschaften fantastische
eigenschaften realität werden die eben
im gegensatz zur simulation diese
richtung in diese neue realität weisen
die fiktion löst uns von der
wirklichkeit die simulation orientiert
uns an dieser wirklichkeit und dieser
spannung zwischen simulation und fiktion
legt die virtuelle realität glaube so
ein mittelding zwischen beiden das
möchte ich jetzt nur zur debatte stellen
und am schluss noch ein beispiel geben
virtuelles geld in online
computerspielen das in euro umgetauscht
werden kann
virtuelles geld hat wirklich einen wert
das können sie in schweizer franken das
können sie in euro umwechseln sie können
sich es auch kaufen
virtuelles geld simuliert erstmal
wirkliches geld und es ist auch
irgendwie fiktiv weil es irgendwie einen
ganz bestimmten namen haben kann denen
es auf der welt gar nicht für eine
währung gibt aber am ende hatte doch
eine realität alles doch realität weil
sie davon wirklich euros bekommen und
wird wenn das geld in online
computerspielen sehen sie schon das
bedarf einer interaktiven gemeinschaft
von nutzerinnen und nutzern die das
gegenteil dass dieser zusammen
anerkennen die also zusammen die
objektivität dieser währung
aufrechterhalten
so ist es nicht nur mit virtueller
währung sollen so ist es natürlich mit
jeder form von währung die kann nur
existieren wenn die bürgerinnen und
bürger wenden käuferinnen und käufer
neben diesen wert gemeinsam anerkennen
und sagen wenn du mir diesen scheint
gibt dann gebe ich dir dafür was anderes
muss also eine form von verbindlichkeit
haben ich glaube dass diese form von
verbindlichkeit für virtuelle realität
sehr zentral ist